Finlandia va a las urnas este domingo
para elecciones parlamentarias los
partidos de ultraderecha Centro derecha
y el gobernante de Centro izquierda
llegan con estimaciones que rondan el
19% cada uno en este contexto la peor
posicionada es la actual primera
ministra sana Marín una deuda pública
equivalente al 73% del pbi una economía
en recesión y una inflación del 8%
atentaron contra la popularidad de la
joven premiere elogiada por sus manejos
de la pandemia y la guerra en Ucrania
hechos que llevaron a que su nombre
suene para puestos en Bruselas
hemos pasado por muchas cosas y hemos
tenido Algunos años difíciles en este
mandato Pero juntos lo hemos superado
porque hay una confianza fundamental en
nuestra sociedad
peteriorpo de la agrupación de Centro
derecha coalición nacional podría ocupar
su lugar Aunque su partido no consiga
ganar los comicios la ultraderecha
podría requerirlo para formar una nueva
colisión
soy muy optimista Tuvimos una gran
campaña tenemos las mejores candidatos
de toda Finlandia y somos los primeros
en las encuestas Así que soy optimista
en las últimas semanas la
ultraderechista rica purra ha ganado
adeptos y desplazó a Marín del segundo
lugar en las encuestas con una política
eurocéptica y ante inmigración el
partido verdadero finlandeses se
posicionó expectante
tenemos esta elección y el pueblo
finlandés los ciudadanos tienen este
poder de decidir Así que estoy
emocionada
puede ser la sorpresa espero ser
positivamente la sorpresa otros seis
bloques están entre las opciones el más
destacado es el histórico partido del
centro principal socio del actual
colisión de gobierno y que advirtió que
no tiene interés en trabajar nuevamente
con Marín sin embargo las estimaciones
lo dan en quinto lugar en lo que sería
su peor participación electoral
cualquiera fuese el resultado el ingreso
de Finlandia alotan no está en peligro
su amplia aceptación entre los partidos
hizo que ni siquiera sea un tema
importante durante la